half a million cyclists take to the
streets of Berlin every day what about
making the carbon-free communities and
greener riding bamboo let me take you to
where these bikes are created ozone
Cyclery began in 2013 just five guys one
dream a bike frame that weighs only a
couple kilos it's still early days at
the startup no mass production yet so
you've got to build these guys itself or
come to a workshop with design being
jostled about information you build upon
yourself how long did it take it took me
four days to make it and someone who's
not a professional it can take four days
it could take ten days and how much does
that cost from 650 euro zone and why
bamboo bamboo is lightweight
fast-growing shock absorbing and very
very durable what happens if it snaps or
you get a tear or breaker it can crack
but that's not a big deal you just put
some glue in and can you could use
repair it each weekend you get three
four people out here building their own
bikes with you guys
Wednesday gonna turn into a real print
we don't know but there's a trend still
in the whole bike field and the trend is
like two people want to express
themselves by by writing a special a
unique bike and to make your own is the
perfect first step for that okay well
let me see if I can discover that
feeling myself I'm gonna take it for
another spin yet yes have fun
thank you see you buddy
let's see what the road ahead reveals
for this small company as they say you
can't reinvent the wheel but you can
improve your carbon footprint